Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 24th,
2014 what's going on?
How are Ya?
Um,
uh,
back in the United States.
Oh.
Say can you
dad fuck is fat chick with the pockets?
Okay.
Buying a hot dog and set up on
right is I get off the tarmac.
She puts some frost is our,
um,
I didn't see that for some reason.
I was picturing a fat woman with the pockets that are at least a foot apart.
You know what I mean?
I don't know why I was thinking that.
I don't know.
I'm,
but I'm back.
I'm in my house.
It's nice to be sleeping in my own bed after a,
you know,
three weeks being away.
It's nice to see the White House was still here and that the people I love are
still,
uh,
in fact not in detention camps.
Um,
it's weird being away that long and then come back.
I'm still,
uh,
still a little more,
a little out of it,
man.
You know,
I'm not a young guy anymore.
It takes me a couple of days to settle back into my routine,
you know,
uh,
Gaman my way through some fucking grape nuts that I let it soak in the FEC and
milk,
you know,
toss a little banana on top of it.
You know,
it's funny,
every time I go to get a banana,
I deliberately don't take the one with the sticker on it.
I take that one last because I worked with the comic who had a bit about it and
every fucking night I had to listen to do this bit about how and which one do we
take the one with the sticker and then what would you do?
You'd stick it on your forehead and he kept fucking opening with the joke of
closing with the,
I just started six times.
I'm talking like 15 fucking years ago to this day.
I will not take a banana first.
That as a staff.
Occasionally I do,
you know,
and somewhere I hear him we won't see.
I told you and I'll be be,
what do you mean you fucking told me?
I,
that's like once in a blue moon and then here's the ghost of his voice is going.
Yeah,
but you're doing it on purpose.
If you didn't hear my bet,
you would have done it every time.
So my jokes,
right?
It's like,
you know,
I'm like,
go fuck yourself.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Well what,
what are you doing?
Talking in my head.
Okay.
This you just be me and all my friends.
Not You.
You're not invited.
All right to fuck you and your,
your,
your theories about the fruit that I consume.
All right.
Everybody is fucking March 24th okay.
And if you live in a colder climate in the northern hemisphere,
you gotta start,
you gotta be getting excited,
right?
Day light savings.
The snow starting to thaw,
right?
The ladies are starting to hit the gym.
You're going to hit the gym.
Every body's going to hit the gym.
You know,
he had comes may
Mae's right around the corner and everybody,
you know,
the guy's got to get out the guns.
The ladies got to show off their thighs.
Everybody has to look desirable.
So somehow they meet that certain,
someone that's just going to hold them at night and tell them that everything's
gonna be okay,
but that's not going to happen.
Right.
Unless you're in shape by make.
So put down those winter cookies.
Everybody may is coming.
April is a fucking wash.
Nobody gives a fuck about April except neo Nazis because Hitler's birthday is
sometime in there.
Right.
And they all get together with their awful haircuts in this stupid mustaches,
you know,
cause they just want to be a part of something.
And they had awful parents who just didn't get them into scouting.
So what did they do instead?
They join the Hitler youth.
You know why?
Because they're weak fucking people.
Okay.
All right.
If you have to go out and join a fucking group,
you know,
at any God damn age,
unless it's something just fun.
I guess being a Neo Nazi,
it's got to have its upsides.
Right.
Okay.
The boots,
you know,
getting a borrow.
Yeah.
The fucking Nazi friends clippers when you share off the side of your skull,
whatever the fuck you do.
Okay.
I know fucking,
I don't want it to fucking talking about,
you know,
fuck groups.
My groups can be all right.
You know,
I guess they can be okay.
I'm trying to think of a good group.
What's a good group?
Like just a group of people that get together in a group and somehow they're not
fucking annoying.
I mean there's even people out there or I agree with what they're doing,
but the second thing,
the group gets the commercial on TV and they just start going,
you know,
every day over 8,000 poodles get their hair straightened against their will.
I mean they start showing the sad 40 I stopped fucking hate and the poodle
people,
I don't hate poodles.
I don't like him.
Okay.
You know,
but I feel like they should wear their hair the way they want to have.
Definitely for that.
But I don't need some fucking former shit.
Calm Star who's put on some God damn booze,
a baby weight coming up the fucking screen in the middle of the Goddamn game
telling me why I got to care about a fucking Pekinese.
Whatever the fuck kind of dog it is.
One of those God damn dogs.
You see fucking walking around in a purse,
right?
He's fucking women walking around.
Never had a babysitter or want to babysit.
Now they've got to have this fucking little primate in there.
Yeah,
you may help me.
Me,
me,
baby.
Do it at the back of the head.
No trial in my world.
If I was running shit.
You know
that probably seems harsh,
but did I say I'd feed my naked uncle to a bunch of dogs like old fat face over
there?
Huh?
How soft as heck.
I look on that fat fuck over there and fucking uh,
what do you call it now in North Korea.
So we're calling it nowadays the all end k,
he looks soft.
You can take that guy down,
you know,
call his number,
little pitch out.
Run the old Packard sweep,
your job's to force it to the inside and I come in,
I fill the fucking lane.
You don't think I'm going to drill in white between his fucking hairless man
tits.
Okay.
And knocked some of his non heard metals right off his fucking uniform.
When you think about that,
I'll do that 45 I'm calling it right now.
Call it right now.
All right.
Red gets the age gap.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Um,
anyway.
Yeah.
So I'm back in town.
I feel like I should have started a song.
Right.
There were like one of those fucking Beatles songs.
Roller Women's starts screaming and yelling,
you know,
in pregnant me.
That's what they say and where are they saying I'll suck it.
I don't know what they're saying,
but all of them are well into their fucking sixties at this point.
All those fucking young women that you hear screaming on that Ed Sullivan show,
he figures to say to me made was like,
what?
13 years old?
That was 50 fucking years ago there.
63 years ago.
63 years old at this point.
You know,
that's how quick it fucking goes.
So that's my message to you this week,
everybody.
All right.
I don't want my,
I have no fucking message.
I'm just happy to be home.
My fucking brains all over the goddamn place,
you know?
It's just all over the fucking place
as it always is.
I don't have any fucking desire to do standup for a while.
I got to tell you,
I got my fill of it and that tour 22 fucking shows doing about an hour and a
half a night.
In 20 days.
I've had enough.
I've had enough of the,
uh,
what's up with the fucking lamp over there?
Okay.
I'm going to take at least 10 days off.
I'm not doing shit.
You guys know,
I came home.
I'm barely left the fucking house.
My Wife's looking at me like I'm a psycho because I'm usually like,
I get home for two seconds,
I throw my bags down and then I walk out the door and she,
she'll just be like,
where are you going?
I'm going.
I'm just like,
I'm like,
I know I'm all fucking wound up.
I just feel like I have to go out and I just,
I dunno where it go.
Drive around and go fucking play drums.
I don't want to do the fuck do I do
drink?
I have no fucking idea.
I can tell you right now though.
Um,
I'm all in with cigar shit though.
After my,
uh,
my,
my second stop in Calgary,
um,
we met like this,
we went to the cigar bar out there for the second time,
me and Versie and uh,
met this character and a half that ran the cigar bar.
Fucking great guy.
And he just,
all he has is Cubans in his,
uh,
in his shop.
And Dude,
he broke down the whole fucking thing,
how they're wrapped,
how to cut the thing and we just go and right.
It'd be like,
you know,
if you played,
I dunno,
a sport and then like a fucking pro came in and just broke your game down to the
basics.
That's what this guy did.
And um,
we smoked these things.
A home going to say it right.
A part of this,
the number twos.
And,
um,
at this point,
that's the only reason why I would get on a fucking plane this week would
literally to be to fly back to Calgary to get a box of those things,
you know,
and then rent like a fucking,
dodge stratus one way the Boise and then jump on a plane and come back.
That's the only fucking reason I do that shit.
I know I'm babbling.
I'm,
I'm all in.
I'm fucking done.
That habit got its hooks in me and uh,
I'm not complaining,
but the great thing is I live in the United States,
so I can't get any fucking Cuban's other than,
than the counterfeit ones.
You know,
all they'll get you give you one that's hard as a fucking rock and it doesn't
have a good draw and you'd just sit sitting there like I might as well as be
smoking it,
Dutch masters.
So,
um,
whatever.
What are you going to,
this will be something I'm going to do when I leave the country.
I'm just going to smoke fucking Cubans and then when I come back,
I'm going to act like it never happened.
You know,
like a sex offender,
right?
It goes to Thailand,
does whatever the fuck he does and then comes back and then you know,
that Shit's not available here and then you just go about your business.
I'll just do that in,
in a,
in a fucking cigar kind of way.
Um,
anyway,
so what the fuck did I want to talk about here?
Um,
but all in,
in,
once again,
I know both thanking everybody for the last few weeks.
Uh,
thank you to everybody who came out to the shows.
That was really a life changing tour and uh,
Canada is now in the loop.
And um,
you know,
when I write my next hour,
I'm going to do the usual toward the states,
usual tour,
Europe,
usual tour of
Australia.
And now Canada is,
I'm added.
I'm adding that.
So that's the deal.
I'm just going to keep expanding the fucking circle and uh,
you know,
fuck else mean.
It's perfect.
I get on a fucking plane.
I sit there,
I read a dumb magazine,
I get off,
there's somebody standing there going,
I you the freckled con that's going to dance like a monkey.
And I say,
I,
I am your huckleberry.
And they see how many bags do you have?
When I say,
well,
I got one
and that goes at your bag right there.
And I say,
you know what it is that it is my bag.
And then when I,
I say,
you don't need to pick it up,
it's got wheels on it.
It's not the fucking 70.
So we gotta be a God damn man,
have some sort of fucking forearm strike that can just carry this like a golf
bag on one of those little wheely things.
We walked to the car,
I go to the hotel,
I get a fucking burger,
go to sleep.
I get up in the morning,
I do the fucking radio when that night to do the show and then I leave.
Okay.
No boss,
no fucking inventory,
no nothing.
I just got a dance like a monkey for a fucking hour.
That's all I got to get my,
I got to get my fucking monkey ass there and then I just do my thing and then I
leave no bullshit,
no conference calls.
Okay.
No support system.
Yeah.
No friends,
no anybody else.
It's just me.
It's not perfect.
Um,
hey.
You know what?
I actually do have to fucking believe it or not,
I do have to take another flight this week.
I can't fucking believe it.
Uh,
because um,
uh,
yours truly as getting ready to,
pick a theater to a shoot is next special may Juneish I'm ready to go.
This hour is ready to go.
Ready to be recorded.
Raised to be put the fucking bed to move on to the next one.
And um,
I'm not excited about going to the airport in I fucking lady,
but I am excited to just fucking land and pick one.
I'm going to try to pick a theater that has a combination of the vibe where I
feel like I'm going to kill in the room and the least Conti Union guys,
you know,
that's basically how I'm going to do it.
You know,
there's fucking union guys.
I'm so pro union,
it's ridiculous.
And then you get around union guys and you're like,
oh,
this is why people don't like you.
And yet,
you know.
Okay.
One of the times,
I can't remember which fucking special it was.
I take the displace right.
And they were acquired to have four guys working the stage.
Cause usually bands play there and I get it.
Okay.
So I gotta pay three guys who weren't going to do fucking shit.
But it's like,
can you at least have the decency to fuck off?
Then go to a back room and play cards rather than just sitting there in the
chair right out in the open.
Like,
look,
yeah.
Yay.
Are you doing shit and you're paying me,
you know,
just have a little fucking tact.
I get it.
It's your house,
your rules.
I'm in your world,
but you know.
Yeah.
Fucking unbelievable.
You've literally become what you were fighting.
I feel,
you know,
maybe I'm just being a Dosha.
Oh,
now,
see now maybe I am,
I don't fucking know.
But uh,
that's what I'm doing this week.
I'm going to pick out a venue and um,
has always been the game plans that get the
figure out roughly what jokes I'm going to try and do and uh,
see what happens that night.
And hopefully I'll do my last special because you know,
you just compete against yourself.
That's all you could do.
Um,
all right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
I,
uh,
I do one of these every single week and uh,
I'm actually recording this Sunday night,
which is why,
um,
it came out a little bit earlier.
I usually record it Monday mornings,
wherever I'm at,
which is why it's called the Monday morning podcast.
Despite the fact that most people consider it,
well,
it should be during mine one day.
You know,
the typical Internet cuts,
the demanding cuts,
who then have turn around and have the nerve to look at celebrities and be like,
oh,
look at,
look at their diva ish behavior.
And they don't see the seed of it in themselves.
You know what I mean?
They don't see that,
you know,
if they actually had their own show,
that may be,
they would be the content.
They never see it.
These internet comments never.
They never fucking see it.
They're the same fucking people that bitch about how there's no original movies
coming out while they go to pirate bay and steal all the movies and nobody can
make any fucking money.
So basically they're either gonna make like a low budget movie at this point.
Are they gonna make a transformers?
Because even if you steal it,
it's not going to be as cool.
I guess if you went down to the Imax and you saw the blue people trying to fuck
each other with the umbilical cords,
whatever the fuck that movie was,
what was that called?
The Argo.
It began with an a action for,
what the fuck was that movie called?
God dammit.
I used that as a reference for like two years.
Apocalypto
yeah,
whatever it was.
It was a fucking chick flick.
It was like if you took the smurfs and you're stretched them out,
you know,
like that good times are that JJ allegedly was painting.
You remember that except you did that with the smarts and then they,
they fucked each other and wrote a dragon.
I think somewhere in there,
there was criticism about America's foreign policy.
I believe it was James Cameron.
Wasn't he the same guy who did the titanic?
Right.
With that chick who punched yourself in the cleavage would sing that song.
Oops.
Okay.
Brian told his ship.
MMM.
All right,
here we go.
Let's do the advertising for this.
Wait,
a legal zoom,
everybody.
Okay.
Legal Zoom,
everyone.
If the excitement of starting your business,
getting your first customer,
and finally quitting your damn job,
has it moved you to action yet?
What?
Here's another good reason to get started.
It's national.
Start Your business month,
everybody.
All right.
National Outta your cubicle
and start your own damn business month at legal zoom and legals a wants to help
you start your own corporation or LLC or file your DBA so you can get up and
running quickly and easily.
Find out why more than 1 million entrepreneurs use legal zoom to start down the
path.
A successful business ownership this month,
only take advantage of their national starch,
your business month special and get a free three month trial of the all new
quickbooks,
making it so much easier to run your business.
That's $119 dollar value for absolutely free.
When you went to Burpee,
you are are in the referral box at checkout.
That's Luke legal zoom.com Promo Code burr legal zoom provides self-help
services and connect and can connect you with the right attorney.
But they are not a law firm.
Legalzoom,
Promo Code burpee you are are fucking hilarious.
I had one read and I butchered the shit out of it.
You know,
that's like the afternoon hockey game,
right?
The team never fucking shows up.
Uh,
speaking of hockey,
how about those Bruins?
Huh?
Good Lord.
I knew that they were on a little run there when I was up in Canada and I saw a
little bit of it,
but I was so damn busy,
I didn't get to watch too many of the games,
although I watched him kick the fucking habs asked for it and not in their own
building.
Um,
yeah,
I believe they've won a,
like 13 in a row.
I watched the last two.
Wait,
look,
a,
they look at how many of they played Phoenix.
It gives a fuck,
right?
Phoenix.
And for the life of me,
I can't remember who they played before that us after it's over,
I don't fucking remember it anymore.
Um,
but either way,
you know what I watched today and I actually,
if the bro,
you know,
if the Bruins don't get to the finals or whatever,
the,
the team that I'm going to root for this year to win the Stanley Cup is a,
is the Saint Louis Blues,
you know,
they've never want a cup.
Okay.
And they've had a lot of bad years and they have great fans and they made a lot
of great moves and the,
you know,
they got Ryan Mellow,
which was a strong move.
And uh,
although I got to tell you if the way they played today against the penguins,
if they're going to start doing that shit,
it's going to be hard to fucking route for him.
You know,
why did they just open up the damn game again and everybody stopped fucking with
this insane goddamn defense and block and the shots are ready.
You know,
I actually looked up some stats this week,
believe it or not.
I'm not just going to just make up shit.
I actually looked it up.
Do you realize Sidney Crosby for all the fucking Goddamn glory they give that
guy,
he's only scored 50 goals in a season once Patrick Kane has never done it.
A can,
I think has done it like twice.
It's a fucking disgrace.
Okay.
I'm not saying it's on them,
just the way the game's played back in the day.
They'd be like four,
five guys who get 50 goals a year for like four seasons in a row.
That was the height.
Fucking Gretzky was getting like 90 60
it was fucking insane.
Guy scored like 300 goals and about five years.
I always one of the greatest,
but I mean there was all those other guy.
Mike Bossy was good for 50 a year for about three,
four years.
You just never see it anymore.
Oh,
fucking get it.
Fucking cock suckers,
man.
Bring in one of the phones back with a defense and it just gets boring after a
while.
Let them
score some goddamn goals.
All right.
The train right there.
Trying to make the pads a little smaller.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
okay.
You know what's funny?
I really have nothing to talk about this week.
I just realized that Shit because I'm not doing anything.
I'm not doing anything.
You know,
they finally started the construction,
the rebuild downstairs after all the fucking bullshit,
the back and forth,
the back in the fall.
It's literally a year later and now they're finally,
uh,
you know,
they finished the upstairs room and then downstairs it was a bunch of crap,
back and forth with that shit.
So I finally got my insurance money back from my,
uh,
mortgage company.
I got all of it back.
And um,
for those of you in the banking system,
you know what that means.
Um,
so they're actually,
they're finally,
uh,
got to rebuild down there,
which is nice.
I'm excited.
But what sucks is everything from downstairs had to fucking come upstairs and
it's an absolute shit show and it's depressing.
It's depressing,
you know?
It's really depressing.
Not that that,
that they're doing this stuff,
it's so I just realized how much fucking shit and the key word is shit that I've
saved over the years that I wish I never saved because now I can't throw it out.
I had this thing where I would fucking any standup show I did if there was a
comedy tee shirt,
I just folded it and I stuck it in a fucking plastic container.
And you know,
I've been doing it for 22 years now.
I have everything back
from the first one I did.
Okay.
Right on through.
I'm ain't got everything.
I got to Jim Norton down and dirty with Jim Norton,
Hoodie,
zip up.
I mean,
I wouldn't throw that one out,
but like some of the other ones,
I have a bunch of comedy central shit and I can't throw it out because I'm
sentimental and it,
but I'm never going to wear any of it.
It's just going to sit in a fucking container until I die.
Um,
so I got rid of all my cassette tapes,
which was a big fucking move from me.
I'm a bit of a pack wreck,
pat rat,
like sentimental kind of thing.
My next move is I'm getting rid of all my fucking cds.
I'm just going to do it.
It's weird.
I get sad when I go to do it and then after I do it,
I feel like this weight off of my chest like is a fucked up thing for you.
When I did a,
uh,
long time ago,
I did a Gig on TV and you know,
it's one of those deals when they had like a hundred comics did it.
And one of the things they did was they give you a,
they gave you a nice piece of luggage,
which I always thought was funny.
Like,
you know,
hey,
did the show,
great job.
Thanks for burning the material.
I get back on the road,
you fucking hack because we own that material now.
You know.
So,
um,
that was back in 2005 and the bag they gave me,
it finally gave out where it was gradually repick oh fuck of Yardi care,
who is gradually ripping.
And then finally my last flight from Newark,
when it was coming down the belt,
I could literally see my clothes in it.
So it was like,
all right,
it's time to get rid of this fucking thing.
Um,
of course I was going to try and get it repaired and get it sewed up.
And my wife was like,
don't,
why don't you just fucking buy a new one?
All right.
So I said,
fine.
So I actually took the bag over to goodwill today with some of the bullshit that
I throw in there and I had to set it down quickly and walk away so I wouldn't be
thinking of like,
but I
got that from that TV Gig.
I did a half hour.
It was important to me and that bag with the gift from it.
Like I'm a fucking idiot.
Like that.
I literally walked up my set it down and the guy at goodwill goes,
thank you sir.
You want a receipt and I was like,
no,
it's all good and I fucking,
that'll run back to the car.
I need to get over that.
I got to kick some shit out of the nest.
I was in my garage.
I've got a bunch of shit in there too that used to be in the place where that
flooded and I'm just looking at all of it,
all of the Games.
I went to,
all of the programs and the hats and all that fucking crap that I got and I was
just like from here on out.
Okay,
I go to a sporting event.
I just keep the ticket stub.
I'm not getting anything else.
No more fucking programs,
no more hats than more hankies towels,
any of that fucking shit because I just save it and I never look at it.
I'm not going to lie.
I got up,
I have a fucking football program from a giant playoff game at the Meadowlands
in 2002 played the vikings or some shit.
I don't know who the hell they play out.
I never read it.
I didn't read it the day I got it.
Jim Fossils on the cover or something to fast [inaudible] fuck you say his name.
He's on the cover.
I have never read the thing.
I'm never gunna read the thing.
Okay.
If I actually took it and put it on fucking Ebay,
I could maybe get 40 cents for it.
What am I doing with it?
And for the rest of my life,
every time I move I'll get water damage.
I that's yet another thing I have to fucking pick up.
So if you're young,
all right.
And you just moved out of your parents' house and he got a little closet full of
shit.
Try to keep it at that.
Sorry for the long pause on Yani here.
All right.
Because uh,
it's just,
it's just a bunch of shit.
I get old cell phones,
old flip phones.
Oh,
old fucking
video recording things.
And I used,
I got all these VHS tapes from when I first did stand up.
Now I got to try and convert those to DVD and then what DVDs running out.
I don't fucking know what to do with all of it.
Um,
so I'm going to get rid of a bunch of shit is what I'm telling you.
And then I'm going to,
I already,
I already fixed my tee shirt game where,
because I'm a sentimental fool.
I don't buy tee shirts that say anything on them anymore.
I just bite plain gray,
black,
red,
white.
That's it.
And when they were out there all pilly looking,
I just fucking toss 'em out and that's it.
I don't remember where I wore them to what and then I'm good.
And uh,
okay.
That's it.
Why,
why am I going through all of this fucking shit?
I also think too,
you know,
the back of my head,
just as a married man now,
you know,
the marriage is going great and everything,
but I'm just saying,
you know,
if you have a good fucking divorced,
right,
get all your shit and get the fuck out.
If you just walk in with like one army bag and just throw like five things in
there and then you
just let her keep the rest of it.
Who gives a fuck?
Right.
You want all those knickknacks up before she just knick knacks.
Those knickknacks?
Is that what you want?
You want the drapes?
Okay.
The throw pillows and all those fucking egg beaters and shit.
Fuck you want,
I can't go to Ikea.
Go buy a bastardized version of the fucking ridiculously nice shit that we had
to buy for some stupid reason.
The dish out eggs and don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
Although I will tell you,
I don't think I could ever go back to apartment living.
You know,
once you get out from fucking living under and over people and smelling their
food and,
and hearing their arguments and listen to their fucking music.
Well why am I yawning so much?
Mary?
Can you guys tonsils you waking you guys up for the work week?
Yeah,
right?
You want to hear some petty shit and a fucking death level.
Did you guys see that Turkey shutdown when a serious jets
serious basically in the middle of a civil war right now.
Right?
So then they have an a battle right along the Turkish border.
So they're in the middle of fighting a fight is Syrian jet pilot is fucking
fighting rebels.
I'm not taking sides here.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
I know our countries with the fucking rebels and Russia's with the fucking,
uh,
powers that be,
but I know both sides don't give a fuck about the Syrian people.
They don't give a shit.
They don't give a fuck about me.
Why the fuck would they give a shit about CMV?
They gave a fuck about the money.
That's what they give a shit about this district,
the strategic bullshit of the fucking wherever the land is or whatever.
That's what they give a fuck about.
So anyways,
this pilot is fighting the good fight.
Okay?
And he's looking for rebels.
And then out of nowhere,
these two Turkish Jetson one comes in and fucking shoots a missile and,
and whatever the fuck it shot at it.
And that shoots the damn plane down.
That's like in hockey,
third man in as a 10 minute misconduct.
That's a game misconduct.
And that's probably a 10 game suspension or is that coming over the boards
first?
I can't remember which,
but whatever.
Turkey with third man in on Syria.
And I was like,
wow,
what the fuck did they do that foreign series?
Like how the fuck could you do that to us?
And then you know what Turkey said,
hang on.
I got it.
There was actually some good shit.
Talk here by Turkey.
I gotta I gotta give it up to Turkey this week.
Shit talker that week.
This is what they said.
Send a Syrian plane,
violated our airspace or f sixteens took off and hit the plane.
Why?
Because if you violate my airspace,
airspace are slap after.
This will be hard.
I know something was lost in translation there.
Okay.
Um,
I liked that though.
I like the way the dude was going.
If you violate my air space,
you know,
like when they have like the,
the fucking grizzled vet cop,
you know,
what is that?
What are those drugs do?
One on my street.
This is my street.
You know that bullshit because if you violate my airspace are slap after.
This will be hard now,
you know,
we didn't say it like that.
Some got lost in translation.
What were you really saying?
Because if you violate my airspace,
I'm going to slap you right in your fucking Syrian face.
I know.
What the fuck he said,
man,
that's too harsh.
So anyways,
that's what they said.
So I read a little bit more and it turns out,
you know what?
Syria did this to Turkey like two fucking years ago.
Turkey said we were just flying some fucking,
you know,
some,
uh,
learn how to fly a jet missions with our guys near the Turkey and Syria and
border and series.
Like ow fuck you.
No you weren't.
You were spying on us.
And they gave him the old right there,
Fred.
They gave him the old right,
right.
Have Fred,
they shut down their fucking jet.
So this is what they're doing over there.
Okay.
That's like literally two children in the back seat talking about who touched
who first and there's shooting down people in jets.
Just fucking unreal.
You don't,
back in the day,
I used to think people who ran countries and we're in a higher power,
there was just something at the core of them,
they will,
they would just,
uh,
yeah,
I dunno,
they will,
there was something wrong with them and that they will,
these evil people in all that type of shit.
And if they just let regular people go doing their fucking thing and everything
would be fine if they weren't so fucking greedy and start rumors about
everybody.
And I don't believe it anymore.
I don't,
I just think it's,
uh,
it's just human nature.
The higher up you go,
the more power you get,
the more of a client you become.
And eventually you get to the point where you have so much power that you want
to fucking make the order to shoot something down as you're standing there and
you fucking rope,
right.
Open robe of course balls hanging out.
He got that red phone.
You just feeling the power coursing through your fucking veins.
You know,
you smoke in a Cohiba.
Oh,
is that what they did?
Well,
we're going to slap them bay.
You get to talk shit,
right?
You get to turn the world into your own fucking video game.
That's what they're doing there.
You know,
like those fucking Weirdos that play video games online and they weigh like
those Mcdonald's headsets and they talk shit and they call each other bitches.
You know,
as they play these war games,
these guys are doing that for real.
I don't know what my fucking point is and all that.
I just think that,
uh,
I know it's not an original theory.
I really believe that we are designed to destroy ourselves eventually and it's
going to happen.
All right.
And what you have to do as a selfish person like me is just pray that it doesn't
happen during your lifetime or at least during the quality years.
You know,
when he gets to those older years,
when you really start slowing down,
you're shuffling years before it becomes the sit down years.
Right.
And then the lay down years and then like the are right already years and then
the fucking,
you know,
whatever.
Then the end,
I just hope it doesn't happen.
You know,
I know the polar ice caps are gonna melt completely.
I know we're not going to do anything about it.
I know New York City,
Miami and all them are going to be underwater.
I know it is.
I just hope it's not during my lifetime.
I mean,
I recycle.
I bring back the cans and the bottles.
I do what I can.
I forget my little fucking recyclable bags.
I go with the paper,
the papers,
right?
The fuck else am I going to do,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
What do you guys think?
Do you guys think we're doomed?
Some people believe that we're going to,
we gotta do something fucking horrific,
right?
And then when we come out of it,
we're where somehow all collectively going to learn a lesson from it.
And then we're going to live in this utopia
and then Jesus comes back.
I can't remember,
but there's so many fucking theories out there.
But I just loved that whole theory that after we fuck it,
have some sort of nuclear holocaust and we somehow survive it and we're sitting
there eating glowing pairs that were somehow
that the,
uh,
basically the,
you know,
what we are,
we're were defective.
That somehow the defect was just going to repair itself.
That we're not going to be petty.
We're not going to be jealous.
I'm not gonna be lustful,
you know,
all the seven deadly sins,
whatever the fuck they are,
you know,
like that cures that.
I don't think it does.
And that's my gloom and doom for this week.
Everybody,
I think we're,
I think we're fucked.
We don't have a goddamn prayer.
But going back,
I am a rooting for the Saint Louis Blues in the West.
I'm rooting for him.
I like Chicago.
I like Saint Louis.
I like the fucking West for some reason I'm liking the ducks.
I don't know why.
I know why.
TEEMU Salani I just liked that guy.
I liked the fact that he weighs less than he did when he fucking was a rookie.
Something to aspire to.
Um,
who else do I like out there?
I never got into San Jose,
although I respect if fans,
I went to a home game,
the fucking rabid.
Um,
I like the kings.
I,
I kind of liked Vancouver until we played him in the finals,
that little jerk off the bite and what's his face on his finger?
And I was kind of weird.
Um,
yeah,
I just liked the west.
The West was cool when I was growing up.
They were good.
Admin team was good.
Calgary was good.
Uh,
I was,
can't do the king sucked until Gretzky got there.
They had their moments though,
right?
I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
But the blues,
the blues were always,
you know,
expansion six,
just never caught a break.
Avocado fuck a break.
So that do,
so that's the team that I'm going to fucking route four.
All right.
And with that,
let's get to some questions.
Mercifully,
let's get to fucking some goddamn questions this week.
Let's see if I can try and make an hour.
I've already looked at it like 10 times.
All right,
37 minutes.
Can I do 23 minutes a bullshit through all of these,
uh,
these questions here.
All right.
Match madness.
Dear Billy brackets.
I'm not a huge college sports fan.
I love sports so I can enjoy a good game,
but I'm not interested in following a season.
March madness is fun for anyone because of the brackets.
If there was another game on a national level with bracket talk and exposure,
you could have a chat.
You could have chest be interesting to watch on TV.
Agree or disagree.
100% agree.
If that's like a great idea.
If they actually had whatever,
I don't even know when the,
the,
the international chess championship is,
but if they set up brackets and they had like,
you know,
four regions,
you broke up,
uh,
the,
the northern hemisphere and the southern hemisphere and the sides of the world.
And he had number one seeds and all that type of Shit Apps,
a Fuckin lutely if he had brackets,
you know,
I went a hundred percent agree with that.
And,
um,
I haven't really watched shit.
I watch a little bit of a tar heel game today and then I fell asleep because,
uh,
I'm fucking old man.
Um,
but I,
I haven't been following any of it,
any of it,
you know,
download the suite six day,
the grade eight,
the final four.
I mean,
I know it's amazing.
I just don't,
uh,
I don't have time.
I have too much fucking invested in the,
uh,
watching hockey and it's coming down to it.
And I,
uh,
I like watching you don't,
so we don't set,
number one,
a big criticism,
especially if people who don't watch hockey.
And on.
Another way I'm going to defend the fucking sport is people say that the regular
season doesn't mean shit.
It's one of the biggest criticisms that gets a regular season judging me.
Jet.
Everybody makes the fucking playoffs.
Yeah.
Kind of like in basketball.
Okay.
How about baseball?
Do you really need to play 162 fucking games to figure out a Windsor Division?
You know,
and then after all that bull shit,
someone's still going to get a wild card.
Okay.
We come on
the only regular season of the four major sports.
That means anything.
It's football.
That's why it's so fucking exciting.
It even,
they are going to fuck that up.
They should have just left it on Sunday.
The Monday night game fine,
but Sunday you play every fucking Sunday.
You don't get a day off.
You play every fucking Sunday.
You don't get a week off.
I mean they just did that to prolong the fucking season.
So they get advertised more now they're going to start working in Thursday
night.
They're going to try to somehow,
if they can figure it out,
they're going to fucking try and do it at least four to five times a God damn
week,
and it's going to ruin the sport.
Just going to ruin it.
All right?
And it's because millionaires can't be happy being millionaires.
They have to try to be billionaires.
And then they got treated to try to be multibillionaires and then they got to
try to go global and they just can't just fucking,
just be like,
Hey,
you know what?
I have enough.
You know,
look at my car,
look at my house,
look at that fucking,
ah,
look at my wife.
Look at her.
She's bending over.
It's my wife.
She had three kids with a good,
she looks,
you know,
that's not enough.
You just got to keep fucking going.
Um,
but yeah,
but that's one of the major things.
Will they say that the,
uh,
the regular season doesn't mean shit?
Um,
I disagree.
I know what you mean.
We're fucking a ton of teams make it,
but uh,
you know,
have to take after league.
Doesn't fucking make it.
I don't want to tell you that's the same way at basketball,
but they don't say that about basketball.
Basketball is the exact same fucking thing.
And the end of the gay,
what it's most,
the,
the most exciting part of the game.
Two minutes to go.
You're up by three.
They stopped the clock like 58 fucking times.
File file,
file timeout,
file,
TV timeout,
technical foul
kicked the ball,
went off his foot.
It just fucking the final two minutes of an NBA game.
I swear to God,
it takes like fucking 18 minutes to play and it destroys.
It's even funny at all the drama.
It's even funnier when you go to a fucking NBA game.
It'll be a gay with playoff implications in anytime there's a stoppage of play,
all hell breaks loose and these fucking shit heads go out and start doing,
uh,
jump a Jackson shooting tee shirts and then they start playing like music way
too fucking loud and it completely takes you out of,
uh,
the drama,
the game.
So I dunno,
whatever,
whatever.
I don't even know why I'm fucking bringing this shit up.
You know why?
Because people who don't watch hockey don't even understand it,
shit all over it.
Whether they have to have times,
have you ever played first of all and it mathematically it doesn't fucking make
sense,
says not to halftime's.
Okay,
there's two 33rd and a third times.
That's what you want to say.
33rd a third time and then it's a fucking 66 and two thirds time.
Um,
if you have a plate your fuck after one shift,
your heart is fucking about ready to come out of your chest.
That's why.
Um,
all right.
Boring.
Here we go.
I'm probably talking about the podcast here.
A dare billion of 25 years old and graduated college a few years ago and had
been living in Chicago since.
I hate it.
Matty h Chicago man.
He goes,
it's not that Chicago,
is it a great city,
but what,
what it is,
but,
but what is it that happens to people when they get in their twenties and
thirties they enjoy the dumbest shit.
I don't want to go to the same bar and taxi around and get food.
No one seems to be interested in anything fun anymore.
The only exercise my friends get is that the gym,
and they don't do anything fun like basketball and none of them are in good
shape because they're on their asses all day.
Everyone is a boring Cielo.
Uh,
there was no spice in their life,
in their lives.
Am I an asshole or are they,
um,
neither.
It's all about what makes you happy.
The people you're hanging out with aren't doing the things that you want to do,
so you're not happy hanging out with them,
but they sound happy as hell to go to the gym and then sit on their ass and he'd
have a beer and eat some fucking Nachos.
And if that's what makes them happy,
they're entitled to it.
What you need to do,
sir or ma'am,
is you need to go find yourself some new French.
You got to go find some active people.
I mean,
there's plenty of,
you're telling me there's nobody in there.
I'll in Chicago,
there's no,
there's not 19,000 fucking pick pickup leaves a hoop hockey flag,
football,
walleyball water polo,
rugby.
There's all kinds of shit you could be doing.
And,
uh,
if I was 25 years old,
I would get into a coed league,
coed fucking league.
You find yourself a pretty girl that likes sports.
You like sports,
she's active,
your active,
you know,
you got a Dick,
she got a vagina.
Yeah.
That way you go,
what more do you need?
Right.
Fuck,
if I go back and be 25 years old again,
I take up field hockey.
The chicks always had fucking beautiful legs,
right?
The TANF fucking thighs,
you know,
short haircuts.
You gotta be like,
all right,
he's still into me.
Are you a Canadian?
To while the same check I'm staring at it,
I'll be your wing man.
Fucking can I watch,
um,
yeah,
dude,
you're not an asshole.
What it is,
is you've decided to continue living an active life at 25 years old as opposed
to just settling in.
You know,
certain people out there,
they get a,
they get old.
They just get fucking,
I mean,
there's a party that you,
you know,
getting old,
you can kind of accept it.
Um,
like I view,
uh,
I love living like an old man.
If it means being smart,
like a,
okay.
Like take it like,
you know,
like if I want to get shit faced.
All right.
Which I do.
I don't know if you guys listened to his podcast every week,
but I like to go out and get,
I like to get fucking hammered.
Um,
I just do it at my house.
Your house is the greatest fucking bar.
You could have a Ba if you're an eight,
if you're in your fucking house.
I don't have upstairs,
downstairs neighbors.
Nothing.
Okay.
I got a wife and a dog and I'm stronger than both of them.
All right.
Well my dog could fuck me up,
but it doesn't realize it.
It loves me so much that it would never turn his pit bull power zone.
But as far as my wife,
I mean,
I'll take it down to the mat.
Right.
And you can tell her I said that.
Um,
so if I want to get fucked up in my own house,
I'm going to do it.
I can fucking put it on the music.
I want to put on,
I can pop in a DVD,
watch a little bit.
Good fellas.
I don't have to deal.
Yeah,
I didn't know what the fuck I'm talking about right now.
I mean,
to me like the way to get shit faced now is for me to be hanging with one other
friend on my front porch,
smoking a cigar and drinking some scotch and listen to some fucking music and
just shooting the shit.
It's quiet,
you know?
Yeah.
When you're younger,
I guess you want the Shit Louder and that type of thing,
but whatever.
But like to me,
I don't feel like an old man doing that.
I just feel like I'm smarter.
Like back in the day,
I used to go into a club,
damaging my hearing in the fucking music was loud and all that type of shit.
But that worked for me back then because I did not as talked to the lady,
by all means drown
out the horrible shit that's coming out of my mouth.
Oh.
With my Zeke have a reaches.
What was I doing?
Uh,
but uh,
yeah.
Don't you know what?
25 is a,
okay,
that's a great age.
And uh,
it's a critical age.
Well,
you're starting to surround yourself with the people that you're really going to
be hanging out with for the rest of your life.
You kind of left most of your high school friends behind.
I'm not in a bad way.
He just,
your paths don't cross anymore,
so you're going to get some new friends and a,
yeah.
Get friends who want to fucking live life.
We want to go do some shit other than,
you know,
hey,
let's go to fucking whatever the fuck they,
what do people go?
What do they go?
Cabos,
St Lucas,
whatever the foil would,
those hacky places.
Everybody.
Let's go into a robot that places everybody goes and then they go there.
They jump off a bar stool in Chicago and then they jump on a bar stool in a,
in a fucking bar pool.
Okay.
It's sit there,
right?
Isn't that great?
It's not as cold and I can piss myself without going to the fucking bathroom.
But we live in a what it's like now,
what kind of doing the same thing in better weather,
better scenery and that type of thing.
Yeah.
If you go to Ruby's should get outside the fucking place and walk around and
hopefully not get murdered like that check,
you know,
and then I'll go find a waterfall and jerk off in it.
You don't enjoy the planet.
All right.
Prince Harry,
uh,
not sure if you heard this recently,
but Prince Harry came out,
I think we say came out of the closet.
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
I got to start watching the news.
He came out and said something to his brother,
the future king that he's not going to be king,
so he doesn't need to be on his best behavior.
Dude,
that's fucking great.
Okay.
You know,
other than his fucking dressing up like a fucking ss officer,
I don't have a problem with that kid.
Uh,
my question to you is,
it's kind of a major other than that time he dressed like Hitler and I,
these bad guy.
Uh,
my question to you is,
what happened if he began to speak out against a trust cities in the world,
like his mother or call out bankers and evil bastards running the world's
resources,
would they bump him off?
Uh,
yeah.
Apps a fucking Lilly.
Oh,
it did.
I call it fucking bit coin thing.
People telling me to get on that.
You've got to invest in this bit coin thing.
They're going to take that thing down there.
They're going to ignore it and laugh at it first.
Just like Gandhi,
you know,
first they ignore you,
then they laugh at you.
Then they fight you,
then you win.
Right.
Isn't that wow?
It goes something like that.
I don't know where to fucking go sport,
whatever.
That bitcoin's shit.
You know?
I'm sure the banks are like that.
I don't think that it's going to be a viable career.
Me,
I won't,
you know,
Jared,
they did all that shit,
right?
Then they started,
you know,
going,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
They get a little bit of traction.
People were talking about this stuff and then what happens?
What happens?
Somebody commits suicide.
Okay.
Conveniently,
conveniently,
and everybody rounds going,
hey,
it doesn't seem like that person commit suicide.
What?
Yeah,
that's what happens when you try to start a new currency.
Okay.
You don't,
what do you think's going to happen?
Do you think these fucking Fuddy duddies I'm gonna fucking Fuddy duddy.
So whatever you say is going to sit around and tolerate that.
The kid,
their whole live lives are,
are,
are invested in the lie of their currency.
You can't come along with a new lie.
Okay?
Then they got to start all over again.
It's like a red sox fan,
but come on a Yankee Fan.
It's not going to happen.
It's not even a Yankee Fan.
It's going to be,
give me a whole new fucking league,
like the XFL eight happening.
Go Fuck Yourself.
The NFL was the,
was where we got our money.
Fuck your league.
Uh,
so anyways,
yeah.
Do I think if he started speaking out against the atrocities a notch,
if he just started speaking out against atrocities,
I don't think,
uh,
what they do is they join it like Kennedy with the civil rights.
We can't control a million African Americans coming into Washington.
What do we do?
We join it and then we'd take control of it.
And then you give you permits and the next thing you know,
they control the fucking thing,
right?
That's what they would do.
They would just join,
you know,
prince,
Prince,
uh,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Dale was his brother's name.
George.
That's a good king name.
The fuck is his name.
Christopher Harry.
And uh,
all right.
If I'm lady die,
if I,
if I was dumb enough to name my,
my second kid,
Harry,
I guess the other one had to be a little bit better,
Larry.
Nah,
there's no way you're going to have to get kids names.
Orion.
What the fuck would his name be?
It's gotta be some English,
some fucking proper.
Not Louie.
That's French.
Is that Henry?
Was Henry.
Is Harry a nickname for Henry out?
Fucking know George.
I'm gonna go with George,
not Jesus.
I feel like the the number five in the line of the family feud.
You know when the first person one,
whatever category it is,
and he said the obvious one.
And then somebody,
the second person said what I was thinking of,
and then three and four somehow didn't get strikes and now it's down to me and
there's like no fucking answer left.
I'm going with George and everybody just looks at me and go,
hey,
good answer.
Good answer.
Right.
Survey says big fucking x.
And then the other team fucking steals it.
And then nobody talks to me at Christmas.
MMM.
Yeah.
The only way that he would actually get whacked is it Philip?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Geez.
What the fuck is she?
Good.
I tell you,
you know the,
the,
they're never around when you need them.
Fuck up by talking about,
got the Internet right here.
Is it Charlie Charles?
Is he named after his dad?
The fuck is his name.
Prince.
I'm just gonna look in Prince.
Prince
Harry.
No possess,
no,
not possessive.
Harry's brother.
I don't know.
His fucking name is Prince Harry's brother
William.
It's my fucking day.
What an asshole.
Oh,
Billy Prince William Doak of Cambridge.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You're name's Billy.
A belly.
Oh,
what are you going to go ride a horse today with your little fucking stick
leaning over,
you know,
be careful too dangerous God damn game.
Prince William.
Uh,
yeah,
they'd whack them either.
The only way they would whack them as if he was effective,
if when they went to join them,
join his,
yeah,
we're sick of that shit too.
That we're,
but we've created or what it was already created and now we have positions,
they pass the baton to us and we're continuing to oppress people.
But that's how we make money.
So we can have a BMW seven series,
right with the bulletproof fucking glass.
Um,
they would join with him and if he said,
no,
you're part of the fucking problem.
And then try,
do it.
Literally attack the sectors that those people were in,
he would definitely get whacked a,
he would die mysteriously.
He'd probably commit suicide air quote.
Um,
okay.
He would have some sort of,
I dunno,
they,
you know,
you know what they do?
What they spray the mist at?
Yeah.
And then you have some sort of fucking they talk about.
He had a hole in his heart that they had never diagnosed before in the head or
rhythmia.
He had a cardiac episode II,
I don't know.
Then the,
then the conspiracy theory would come out and then all the other fucking moron
mouth breathing,
conspiracy theories would muddy up.
The real conspiracy theory in the whole fucking thing would go away.
That,
that's my guess.
There you go.
That's my guess.
Jesus Christ.
I almost did it.
55 fucking minutes.
55 minutes.
How are you guys doing?
Hey,
you listen to this early.
What is it?
10 30 in the morning getting ready for your break.
It's a roach coach.
Pullin up.
You got to go get some Drake's cakes.
No,
fucking sausage king.
Is that what you're going to do?
All right.
Live forever.
Forever.
Billy infinity.
I hate when people,
I hear people say,
who would want to live that long?
Uh,
I guess he's referring,
she's referring to when someone is like,
just they just turn 102 who,
who'd want to live a look?
A this guy says give me a pulse as long as possible to people who say they
wouldn't want to live forever.
What do you say to that?
Uh,
well,
I mean it comes down to quality of life.
I mean,
the human body is designed to live for 150 years.
And then after all the abuse that we do to what you usually drop it above
fucking I guess 75.
Um,
I mean,
I wouldn't want to live forever if like I was just sitting there like looking
like Yoda,
but without his fucking ability to flip around the room with a light saber.
Um,
what I want to live forever.
MMM.
Yeah.
If there's nothing after this,
fuck yeah.
But I mean,
you know,
but then what you do is you,
you would,
you would watch a slowly kill ourselves and then we would become extinct and
then you'd be the only one left and then they'd be the next people.
Right.
Like I've told you guys my theory,
right,
that I,
I feel like water is the toxic waste from the last people that fucked up this
planet.
And that is absolutely poisonous and toxic to them.
But we,
we,
we came out of it,
you know,
and we're walking around thinking of what good looking,
but we're all a bunch of fucking mutants compared to the last people when we
don't know any better because we can't look at them,
right?
So when we're done fucking up this planet,
the next people will come out of the,
out of the soup that we leave,
which will have plastics and fucking,
uh,
you know,
old computers and all that shit.
God knows what the fuck they going to look like.
You know,
like,
I don't even know.
But you know,
if you live forever,
you'd be around for them.
Okay.
No,
I wouldn't want to live forever.
I wouldn't want to live forever because I think eventually as planned,
it's going to look like Mars and then you would just be sitting there.
Well,
what would you do?
Shit.
And they're kicking fucking moon rocks around forever.
That's fucking scary.
Do you just couldn't die.
I Dunno what I do.
You know what I do is I would try to wait.
There's no,
there's no technology to do it.
I would get a fucking spaceship and fly to the next earth
and I had land there and hope that they kind of looked like me.
It wasn't the dinosaur period or whatever.
And you know,
this is it.
Like some of them was saying there's like a,
you know,
there's a bunch of earth's out there,
tens of thousands of them throughout the fucking space.
Solar system.
I know what the fuck the word is.
Oh Jesus.
I'm tired.
You know guys,
sometimes these fucking questions they did
like,
do you guys realize that the level of thought that how dumb I am,
that you got to fucking sit there in March.
Madness bracket sits right in the fucking wheel house.
I guess two or easy.
My,
well,
my wheelhouse,
you know Prince Harry,
you don't even give me his brother's name and then I got to find out is my own
fucking name.
And you even said bill in it.
So the answer was there.
It was a Clo.
Yeah.
Then what I,
what I want to live forever.
I have to tell you,
I do want to see the seventies again.
I was born in 1968.
I'd love to like to live to about 2072,
you know,
provided New York and Miami on underwater.
That changes the whole deal.
Um,
once that shit starts happening and then out and then I don't give a fuck,
you know,
Oh,
I'm bandwagon humanity.
I'm here for the good times.
Once it starts going the other fucking direction,
you know,
I'm,
I'm tapping out.
Okay.
I you this,
there's,
I don't have any red dawn in me.
Okay.
You know,
I mean I would go up in a tower and just start fucking shooting at the powers
that be,
I would do that.
Ah,
I was kidding me.
I'd be a pussy.
I couldn't do that cause I'd be like,
Oh that guy coming at me.
It's just in his choice.
He's just taking orders so I just shoot over their heads.
I commit suicide that way.
You don't only do the people death by cop.
I do it that way.
I think
that'll fucking know.
All I know is I'm back home and I had a great tour up in Canada,
underrated.
Remember that I used to that overrated,
underrated for the fucking week.
Uh,
underrated Canada man,
Canada,
Canada.
You got to fucking get up there dude.
It's fucking,
it's unreal.
And the maritime,
uh,
specifically,
I would definitely hit up there.
Uh,
if you're a cigar smoker,
you're out of your mind.
You've got to get up there.
Uh,
you know,
I was watching the single,
the Bruins and they've got this great segment that they do where they interview
the Bruins and it's just like they talked to him for three minutes where no
hockey questions.
It's really great in every,
you can see every player they so sick,
it's answering questions about playing hockey that all of them it seems when
they're interviewing them,
they're already having a good time just to,
he'd be here in new questions and,
uh,
Brad Marchand who then said he can call a Marshawn,
he doesn't give a fuck.
So I'm going back to Marshawn is actually an avid hunter and I believe he's from
Halifax or somewhere around there.
And um,
yeah,
he shot big shit like bear and he's going to go after elk and a next,
and I honestly,
I,
that's,
I couldn't do that.
I don't think I could do that.
I could shoot a chicken,
right?
I could shoot a cow,
but if I didn't kill it on the first shot,
I would hear that awful mooing for the rest of my fucking life.
Why wouldn't you to cow and she would,
uh,
steer
man,
that's a gun's jam.
Ugh.
Oh my God.
It'd be fucking horrible.
But I gotta be honest with you.
If everybody listened to this podcast,
if you are hungry enough,
you would,
you would fucking eat a puppy.
Okay.
Sad reality.
Just the,
your,
your love of cute things versus I'm going to fucking die if I don't eat you.
It just goes right out the goddamn window.
You know,
what's the biggest animal you think you could kill?
Biggest animal I could kill.
Be Jonah.
Rosa.
He's a fucking animal.
Um,
actually what do we got here?
Am I over an hour?
Did I make it all right?
Now we're in three minutes.
Okay.
That's a podcast for this week.
Everybody.
This was sort of my hung over.
I had a great time up in Canada podcast.
Uh Oh,
by the way,
that Paul Versey,
Jason Lawhead,
Joe Bart,
nick toward that is the Monday morning podcast is sponsoring.
It's the all in tour.
Um,
and the first date is that Lago.
And I'm actually going to be hosting that one and a,
and kicking off the tour.
All these guys and the past of open for me and now they're a spreading their
wings,
doing their own fucking towards.
I'm so proud of,
um,
and I'm going to be hosting the first one down at Largo.
It's already sold out.
And uh,
we're going to be kicking that one off.
And then these guys,
I'm telling you,
I don't bring cupcakes out on the road.
These guys are all killers.
So if you want to see three guys,
guys,
alright,
no fucking,
none of that awkward.
You know,
they don't say apparently before every fucking punchline.
All right.
Not saying that's bad,
but I'm just saying it's not that fucking style.
All right.
Uh,
if you want to listen to three guys,
fucking hilarious,
who you probably would sit next to win a bar.
These are the guys,
the all end tour.
We're going to be getting the dates up soon.
Uh,
they're going to have a fucking cool last poster.
I've already heard the concept.
I fucking love it.
And uh,
I'm proud of these guys and it's going to be a great tour.
So,
uh,
definitely be looking for that and uh,
oh fucking freckled face here is done.
I am done with standup comedy until the end of April.
I'm not doing shit.
I am a relaxing and,
um,
I think the song,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do my,
my standup from here on out.
I'm just going to fucking go out and go psycho for fucking 20 days and then take
like a month and a half off and then do another cycle fucking tour.
And I sort of got to do all in nothing,
just the same way I drink,
just fucking pounding.
And then just,
I take a fucking year off for 70 days off and then I pound for another 70 days.
That's it.
All enough to,
that's how I'm going to do it.
All right.
Uh,
that's the podcast for this.
As always.
Thank you for everybody for listening.
I hope you have a wonderful week.
Don't take any shit.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
And a,
any predictions,
any predictions mean VRC is still talking about that fucking horrific flight
that they can't find and he thinks it's on the ground.
I think it's unfortunately a,
you know,
I think it's unfair.
I actually,
that,
that review that I,
that prediction that that pilot made the,
he thought there was some sort of fire on board or something.
Man,
it seems like it's that fucking that is anything just hanging in the air.
You just want the answer to.
It's gotta be that man.
It was fucking poor families.
Why do I bring,
it was awful last week when we brought it up.
Why would I end the podcast bringing that up?
Stupid stupid fucking move.
But you know what?
You don't listen to this thing cuts.
I'm smart.
That's it.
All right.
I got nothing to predict.
I got something projected on macro do shit between here and next week.
I better get a fucking guest.
I actually got a call,
Don.
My rare,
I'm going to try to do one with him.
Yeah.
Dom,
I rare raw dom.
I rare ree.
You are a Talia and you're not Germane.
Your not.
I reassured
Jew.
I'm gonna leave that on his fucking answer machine.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll see you.